foreign
mom
[Music]
[Applause]
why are you looking at me like that
hello everyone and welcome to a new
episode of RT Essentials I'm Mark Ellis
today we're looking at the body of work
of one M Night Shyamalan who pretty much
directs rights and co-produces all of
his own stuff and just a heads up I'll
probably be saying the word shamawanawa
today so I'll mix in some night some M
uh the director here and there look the
guy wears many hats speaking of which Mr
s has also been behind a couple of fresh
Series in Wayward Pines and servant
serving as executive producer and
director but if you know what it means
when somebody Whispers the phrase I see
you probably know him first and foremost
as a filmmaker and that's what we're
focused on here today so with plenty of
twist endings and director cameos ahead
here is our list of the highest rated M
Night Shyamalan movies right now on RT
Essentials
happening just let me think
oh
I need a second okay just give me a
second you're not gonna be one of those
on the news and watches a crime happen
and not do something we're not just a
second you were children in that guy
please
I need a second okay why shouldn't
anybody give me a god second and we just
so happen to be kicking things off with
2008's the happening this sci-fi drama
Stars Mark Wahlberg is a science teacher
who along with his wife played by Zooey
Deschanel and a young girl played by
Ashlyn Sanchez worked to survive amidst
a plague that is causing those infected
to commit suicide they head to the
Farmland of Pennsylvania but eventually
learned that nobody is safe from this
Invisible Killer after an impressive run
of mostly successes director writer
producer M Night Shyamalan was coming
off the 2006's lady in the water which
was considered a critical and Commercial
failure because of that he struggled to
get his next script sold which was then
called the green effect but after taking
feedback from Studios he rewrote the
screenplay and eventually got it sold as
The Happening which would become his
first ever R-rated film he had Wahlberg
in mind for the lead role and luckily
the actor came on board
just going to talk in a very positive
manner giving off Good Vibes
we're just here to use the bathroom
then we're just gonna leave
I hope that's okay
elastic
talking to a blasting plant and even
though the happening growth 163 million
dollars with a budget of just 50 mil and
performed very well with DVD sales too
the film was panned by critics and is
currently sporting a rotten 17 on the
Tomato Meter I mean look it's a 10 movie
list they can't all be winners right
John Bond told the New York daily news
during filming that his goal was to make
an excellent Bee Movie and later thought
that maybe viewers didn't quite see it
and appreciate it that way a best horror
film nomination at the Saturn Awards was
outshined by the movie's four Razzie
nominations which included worst picture
along with horse director and worst
screenplay for Shyamalan but while most
critics tore it apart author Stephen
King was actually singing shyamalan's
praises saying that he really
understands fear and appreciated as the
Director finally let himself go with an
R-rated movie that's High Praise from a
king Lady in the Water I don't know who
you are
but you did something to me
my thoughts
if everything became clearer
the fears that were muddling my thoughts
just went away
I hear myself
do you wish to know your future
swimming up to the next spot on this
list is 2006's waiting in the water this
film stars Paula Giamatti as an
apartment building superintendent who
rescues what he thinks is a young woman
played by Bryce Dallas Howard from the
pool but as he falls deeply in love with
her he begins to learn that she is
actually a character from a bedtime
story which he and his fellow tenants
are also a part of M Night Shyamalan who
once again served as director writer
producer developed a script from a
bedtime story he told his kids about
what happens in their pool at night in
fact he also wrote a children's book
called A Lady in the Water a bedtime
story to coincide with the film I mean
this guy's a Swiss army knife of talent
and this time around rather than his
usual Cameo appearance Shyamalan gave
himself a much bigger role he plays a
writer struggling to finish a book that
as we learned would come to inspire a
future president to greatly change the
world so lost without you guys
foreign
and it turns out that character along
with an arrogant film critic who meets a
violent and are a big part of why
critics had trouble connecting with this
film and ultimately dismantled it in
their reviews like top RT critic Trevor
Johnston from time out who wrote what
was shot alone thinking this isn't just
Duff it's career threatening
catastrophic on top of that lady in the
water marked the lowest opening of
shyamalan's career at the time and went
on to gross to 72 million dollars
against a 70 million dollar budget it
was nominated for poor Razzie Awards
including worst film and worst
screenplay and one two for worst
director and worst supporting actor both
for Shyamalan but hey let's just swim to
the next movie
glass she said I have one job to do keep
Kevin out of the light so I'm sorry you
won't see him anymore
and you have to listen to her right
because she's an adult and you're not
duh yeah
crying Jesus
listen I don't know about these other
guys but we are like a superhero no
we're like
we're not crazy
bringing some transparency to this list
next is 2019's glass this film marks the
13th movie for M Night Shyamalan and
serves as a crossover and sequel to his
previous film's unbreakable and split
making it the third and final
installment in what has come to be known
as the unbreakable trilogy there is a
16-year gap between those first two
movies but once Bruce Willis made a
cameo at the end of split to tie the
universes together and set up a big
showdown in glass Shaman officially had
a Trilogy on his hands and got to work
on this one and along with deleted
footage from unbreakable being edited
into it this film features Willis Samuel
Jackson James McAvoy and Anya Taylor Joy
reprising their roles from previous
movies and with Shaman once again in his
cameo role of jai who's now security
guard this time Wilson's David Dunn is
using his abilities to try and catch
mcavoy's Kevin Crum and his many
personalities
[Music]
yeah
please
one of the Void they need to walk us out
of here if that's okay
partner
[Music]
speaking of shovel on tried to show more
of Kevin's Personalities in this movie
but It ultimately led to a three and a
half hour run time for The film's First
Cut so three of those personalities were
ultimately sent to The Cutting Room or
the end result was another box office
success and Best Director nomination at
the freight meter awards for Shyamalan
but even though he once called it the
first truly grounded comic book movie
the critics didn't necessarily agree and
this is the only rotten film in the
unbreakable trilogy The Village I love
you more than the Sun and the Moon
together and if you feel the same way
then we should not hide it any longer
it's a gift love is
we should be thankful we should Bellow
it out with all the breath in our lungs
thank you
thank you thank you
[Applause]
gathering together for the next spot on
this list is 2004's The Village this
marks End by Sean Milan's first period
film and stars Bryce Dallas Howard
Joaquin Phoenix and Adrian Brody they're
all members of a 19th century community
that constantly lives in fear of the
strange creatures that are inhabiting
the surrounding forest and if you're
keeping score at home writer slash
director slash producer Sean Milan's
customary Cameo appearance features him
as a guard at a desk in this movie The
set used in the village was built in a
field in Pennsylvania the state where
most of M night's movies are made with a
temporary Sound Stage set up nearby as
well but not only did the director run
into delays after there was a lack of
Fall Foliage due to a late fall which is
so classic he also ended up calling back
all the main players for some reshoots
five months after filming wrapped which
was reportedly to try and change the
ending
yeah
let's close the door
Lucius is outside walking they're coming
he's in
somewhere please close the door
he'll come back to make sure we're safe
ultimately though the village which is
right on the Tomato Meter got mixed
reviews from critics especially that
ending top RT critic Emily Saint James
from box called it perhaps the greatest
sequence Shaman has ever filmed while
the overall critic consensus says the
village is appropriately creepy but
shyamalan's signature twist ending
disappoints either way this one did well
at the box office to the tune of 257
million dollars against the 60 million
dollar budget and frequent Shaman
collaborator James Newton Howard
received an Oscar nomination for best
original score other accolades included
a Best Director nomination for M Night
at the Empire Awards along with best
actress and best newcomer Noms for Bryce
Dallas Howard and what was one of her
first big roles old what did you do they
were just playing it's okay
it's got a little fat mom you're better
[Music]
Maddox it's okay Chen
just to let Mom and Dad figure this out
it's okay right Mom next up on our list
of the highest rated M Night Shyamalan
movies is 2021's old the film is based
on the French language Swiss graphic
novel sand castle by Pierre Oscar Levy
and Frederick Peters it follows a
vacationing family who discovered that
the secluded beach they've been chilling
on is somehow causing them to age
rapidly and ultimately reducing their
entire lives into a single day Shyamalan
who plays a resort employee that drives
the guests to the beach in this one
decided to adapt the graphic novel into
a movie after receiving it as a Father's
Day gift in 2017. he said old was partly
about our dysfunctional relationship the
time and also said that the film's focus
on Aging also reminded him of his own
father who had dementia
there's no place I want to be
but with you
do you believe me
I want to be here
right now
filming took place in the Dominican
Republic for three months during the
covid-19 pandemic while there Shyamalan
was said to have used storyboards to
frame every shot in the film presumably
to keep things as efficient as possible
the film opened in the summer of 2021
and performed well at the box office and
also picked up a People's Choice Award
nomination for drama movie of the year
and a Saturn award nomination for best
thriller film but in the end critics and
fans delivered some polarizing reviews
for old which is at a rotten 50 percent
on the Tomato meal the critics consensus
says shamwan's uneven execution will
Intrigue or annoy viewers with little
middle ground between while the general
feeling from moviegoers is that love him
or hate him no one makes movies quite
like M Night Shyamalan and no one else
could have made old
the visit I'm going to get you back
[Laughter]
I'm making chicken pot pie stopping by
next on this list is 2015's the visit
this film centers around two young
siblings who go to spend a week with
their estranged grandparents at their
Farmhouse but as the visit goes on the
kids grow more and more scared by their
grandparents Disturbing Behavior and my
Shyamalan was coming off a couple
critical failures in The Last Airbender
and after Earth and ended up funding
this movie on his own that included
borrowing money against his house and
using his fee from After Earth he said
it was an attempt for him to regain
artistic control after a few of his more
recent offerings have been denied Final
Cut and it resulted in what his lowest
budgeted Studio feature was to date but
it turns out that getting final cutback
had its challenges for Shyamalan who
admitted to having trouble keeping the
right tone throughout his various cuts
of the film veered hard towards Styles
like Art House comedy and horror before
finally settling somewhere in between
with his final vision
wear a Nana and pop-up
you've been staying with those people
the whole time
Masonville Police Department
and given the found footage and low
budget nature of the visit this became a
project of first for Mr Shyamalan for
one he didn't make his usual Cameo
appearance and he also didn't work with
his usual longtime composer James Newton
Howard this also became shyamalan's
first film since the village in 2004 to
not be the darling of the Razzie award
in fact enlight was actually nominated
for the Razzie Redeemer award instead
the visit pulled in nearly 100 million
dollars against its 5 million dollar
budget and at least according to the
critics consensus signaled a welcome
return to form for writer director M
Night Shyamalan unbreakable characters
and Comics are often attributed special
powers invisibility x-ray vision things
of that sort
I don't want to play this game anymore
it's an exaggeration of the truth
maybe it's based on something as simple
as instinct
you might not have been carrying
anything but he might have been carrying
a silver gun with a black grip tucked in
his pants good
gotta go making a dent next on this list
is 2000's unbreakable this film is
considered to be the first installment
in the unbreakable Trilogy it introduces
the character of David Dunn played by
Bruce Willis who survives a train crash
with no injuries and eventually comes to
the realization that he has superhuman
abilities Willis was reunited with
Samuel L Jackson after appearing
together in movies like Pulp Fiction and
Die Hard with a Vengeance and he also
teamed up with M Night Shyamalan for a
second time after the ultra successful
Sixth Sense this began the director's
first of what would be three Cameo
appearances as the character of jai who
is in this movie as a stadium drug
dealer Sean Malad had actually already
talked to Willis about the lead role
during their time together on the sixth
sense and given the film's success made
it even easier to get the screenplay
sold Disney bought it for 5 million
dollars a spec script record at the time
and he was also given another five
million dollars to direct
why are you looking me like that
you're trained derailed
some kind of malfunction
they only found two people alive so far
you
this call was cracked open and most of
his left side was crushed
and to answer your question there are
two reasons why I'm looking at you like
this
one because it seems in a few minutes
that you'll officially be the only
Survivor of this train wreck
and two
because you didn't break one bone
don't have a scratch them on you but
despite all those zeros in his paycheck
Sean watt said that he wanted to Market
unbreakable as a comic book movie but
Disney which was pre-marvel at this
point wanted to push it as a
supernatural Thriller you know like the
Sixth Sense eventually though M night's
realistic vision of the superhero genre
caught on Big Time with the right kind
of fans and has gained a strong cult
following and the fresh unbreakable also
found box office success and according
to top RT critic Peter Bradshaw from the
guardian marked the maturity of M night
shyamwan as a distinctive even
remarkable filmmaker and of course 16
years later came the follow-up film
split with rose proprising his role in a
brief Cameo and the third film glass a
couple years later
signs
[Applause]
hosting up next on this list is 2002's
sign Mel Gibson stars as a former priest
who discovers a series of crop circles
in his cornfield which he learns are the
result of extraterrestrial life the film
also features Joaquin Phoenix who
replaced Mark Ruffalo at the last minute
that's a fun trivia nugget along with
Rory Culkin and Abigail Breslin in
supporting role plus we got M Night
Shyamalan in a standard Cameo appearance
this time he was a veterinarian named
Ray ready this project grew out of
shambaland's idea to show an alien
invasion from one family's perspective
and he actually made it quite personal
with his own family using the stories of
his kids bursts in the film and also
featuring the artwork of his daughter
Celica Sean won called this his most
popcorn movie at the time and looked at
Classics like the birds Night of the
Living Dead and Invasion of the Body
Snatchers for inspiration he even had
the cast watch the birds several times
during production move children dominoes
is behind behind
oh
and in an attempt to make things more
ominous he moved away from the more
common weed field setting for crop
circles in favor of corn fields with
their taller and more menacing stalks
good places for ETS to hide the
certified fresh signs crushed it at the
box office bringing in nearly a half a
billion dollars against a 72 million
dollar budget which is not too shabby
and the consensus from Critics on this
one said the chamelan proved once again
to be an expert at building suspense and
giving audiences the chills
split
I thought I lost you
[Music]
could you uh
did you step outside please
[Music]
you like to make fun of us
but we are more powerful than you think
step outside
[Music]
coming together next on this list is
2016's split we've been hitting that at
all episode long this film is the second
installment in M Night shyamalan's
unbreakable Trilogy and it stars James
McAvoy is a man with dissociative
identity disorder and 23 distinct
personalities he kidnaps three teenage
girls and keeps them in an underground
isolated facility but they have to try
and Escape before what is supposedly the
emergence of an even scarier 24th
personality Shyamalan returns as his
Cameo character from unbreakable Jai who
is now an apartment building security
guard and while the director did make it
into the film Sterling K Brown was cast
and filmed for a role that was later cut
on account of not being ultimately
necessary to the story mcavoy's
character was necessary however and he
got the gig after a chance meeting with
Sean won at of all things Comic-Con
McAvoy happened to be sporting a near
bald head after filming X-Men apocalypse
and seemed to have the right look
[Music]
you're a big fibber
I never lie that way bye
but Mr Dennis
he said that he followed those two girls
for four days and that he knew that they
were the ones that that he would want
that work was for the character Kevin
Wendell Crump who first appeared in an
early draft of Shaman's unbreakable
script but was later pulled out in the
interest of time so the writer director
recycled some of those early scenes
years later for split but despite being
a sequel to the very successful
unbreakable split was not marketed that
way in order to protect the revelation
of Bruce Willis's Cameo luckily though
fans appreciate what they dubbed a
stealth sequel that is also one of the
first solo super villain origin films
the certified fresh movie was a hit with
critics and fans pulling in nearly 280
million dollars to become M night's
fifth feature to earn nine figures and
as you've already heard plenty already
today it was followed by the movie can
you name it you remember it was called
glass
The Sixth Sense she says she's sorry for
taking the Bumblebee pendant she just
likes it a lot
what
Grandma comes to this busy sometimes
well that's very wrong
Grandma's gone you know that I know
she wanted me to tell you she wanted me
to tell you she saw you dance
and the final installment on this list
of the highest rated M Night Shyamalan
movies is you guessed it 1999 is the
Sixth Sense this is the film that
introduced the world to Sean lawn and is
trademark surprise twist endings it
stars Haley Joel Osmond as the young boy
haunted by the fact that he is visited
by Ghost and the only one is not too
afraid to talk to about it is Dr Malcolm
Crowe played by Bruce Willis John Juan
makes what would become his usual Cameo
this time as a doctor which was a
tribute to his many family members who
are doctors the cast also includes Tony
Collette who auditioned for this film as
an afterthought while in New York City
on another audition Donnie Wahlberg lost
43 pounds for the roll and Michael Sarah
said that this film was the first movie
he ever read for Shaman reportedly
pitched this film as a cross between The
Exorcist and Ordinary People he already
had Willis in mind for the lead role
which worked out with osmic coming on
board at age 11 to play the
nine-year-old Cole and it's Cole who
delivers the iconic line I see and
people
[Music]
which is widely considered as one of the
most famous movie lines of all time the
Sixth Sense open on August 6 1999 which
is Emma shyamalan's birthday and went on
to become the second highest grossing
film of the Year behind Star Wars
Episode 1 The Phantom Menace and was
then rented by 80 million people in 2000
making it the year's top rated VHS and
DVD title this film was nominated for
six Academy Awards including best
picture best director for Shyamalan and
best supporting actor awards for Osman
and Colette and perhaps more importantly
it set a course for Shyamalan to change
the face of Cinema for years to come
well there you have it our list of the
highest rated M Night Shyamalan movies
tell us which one is your favorite and
is there one that didn't make this list
that you secretly love is it about an
airbender who's not first we'd love to
know you know I gotta say I thought I'd
be pretty Shyamalan down after all these
movies but I think I'm ready to go back
and watch him thanks for tuning in to RT
Essentials I'm your host Mark Ellis I'll
see you and probably some dead people
next time
no twist ending you
[Music]